this is actually probably a pretty good
time to transition to the jeff bezos
picture honestly this is the picture
right here look at this you see that
tweet that said uh this is like every
couple in arizona yes it's so funny
that's exactly what i was thinking when
i saw this so jeff bezos for everyone
listening posted a picture of himself on
new year's eve with his new wife and
he's just like i guess it's 70s themed
or something yeah he's he's wearing
white pants and a crazy ass shirt tucked
in and the caption says we had so much
fun
last night celebrating with a crazy
disco party with family but the new year
is also a great time to take stock and
focus on personal growth renewal rebirth
and paying careful attention to each
moment of your life the good and the bad
all of it celebrate and grow and then
his wife is the top
most liked comment and it's she says i
love you baby for every reason and no
reason
it's funny watching because you know
jeff
is not an influencer so watching him
like move through the stages of
influencer like as far as like his
social presence now he still is like a
local like this picture is very local
it's not done professionally it's not
done well he's not trying to be cool you
know like i think anyone else would like
maybe have like stood still no smile
like try to put on like a
you know like i'm a dope as [ __ ]
presentation but he's still in that
stage where he's like let's get a
picture
yeah and then write some caption like
you could take this caption and you
could stick this on a post from one of
your friends from high school you could
stick it on one of the a bitcoin
influencer's post and it would work it
would work fine yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah focus on personal growth
renewal rebirth he's not saying anything
here everyone says this [ __ ] on new
year's eve and then for his girlfriend
to back it up and be like i love you for
every reason and no reason it's like
well
how why do you love them then that makes
no sense i'm also hoping that they you
know jeff takes the proper arc as an
influencer i really hope he doesn't
pitfall into a couple's account i mean
wait elaborate on that so you know i'm
hoping that like he starts to figure it
out and then you know maybe he starts
like he starts dressing a little
designer
you know starts stops smiling in
pictures starts standing still
maybe he [ __ ] on occasion you know he
might stand up a little bit and just
like oh yeah okay
throw just throw a casual like ice in my
veins or like start posing like this yep
so proud of the blue origin team for
another successful landing of our [ __ ]
and he's like this next to the team
[Music]
you got to think cooler man the caption
has to be blue origin going up all year
rocket ship that's yeah i'm kind of
thinking i'm kind of thinking he's still
got his pr team writing the captions
because they have to go through like
layers and layers of legal review he
only sends them one picture and they're
like jeff can you please start like
looking up in these pictures he's like
nah you know either way that's the arc
we hope he takes i can you imagine if he
takes the other way and he's like i'm
announcing that me and mrs bezos will be
now sharing our instagram and you're
like
and the
what's the name the bezos's
uh yeah you know or it's just bezos
besos
and their profile picture is like them
too on a white psych with like you know
just like it's just you know and then
all their pictures are then like eating
[ __ ] yogurt and yeah and it's like
farmers markets and [ __ ] and you're just
like
it's like sunday with my ride or die and
it's them at a pool
in tucson it's every day with your ride
or die jeff i love you for every reason
and no reason i feel like that's
insulting i love you for i can't even
think of a reason right now
maybe that's her way of saying you know
it's just uncontrollable when she gets
around you know jeff can we pull up that
picture of him on the yacht too you see
this paparazzi shot of course man of him
paparazzi shot [ __ ] out of here he hired
that shot so then he's getting better as
an influencer
that's the next stage this is him right
here that's that's not the best picture
there's another one of him standing like
more to the side
i mean but i mean you can see you can
see look at that look at the vascularity
that our boy is wide dude he's like 60
is he not yeah he's ready for his
[ __ ] aew appearance man that's is
that next do you think he's gonna do a
wrestling appearance
yeah
that would be so sick
for all you amazon workers in the
audience tonight your boss is here he
comes out bam bam bam bam yeah
jeff
pesos
that's his secret move that's his secret
move he's got his opponent on the ropes
and he just laughs
there's skin
the guys are there g-forces